depuis qu'il a présenté au monde son
petit archie l'image de sa mère revient
le hanter
en 1984 c'est lui que l'on montrait à la
presse dans les bras de diana
il avait à peine 13 ans quand elle est
morte sous le pont de l'alma à paris
pourchassés par des paparazzi et depuis
le début de leur histoire
c'est leur hantise meghan markle le
disait sans détour cet automne et les
tabloïds ne l'ont pas épargné
capricieuse dépensière autoritaire des
commentaires racistes aussi sur ses
origines afro américaine cet automne
c'est la goutte d'eau
le mail on sunday avait publié une
lettre de mégane à son père ils
attaquent en justice
et le ton du communiqué du prince harry
laisse déjà présager de l'avenir
ces comportements détruisent les gens et
détruisent des vies
c'est de l'intimidation ce que je crains
le plus c'est que l'histoire se répète
j'ai perdu ma mère et ma femme est en
train de subir le même sort
le couple pèse environ 50 millions de
dollars
une bonne base pour atteindre
l'indépendance financière
athenes une actrice duchesse avec un
prince qui a su utiliser la marque de la
famille royale pour maintenant créer la
leur il ya un gros risque selon l'ancien
correspondant royal de la bbc alan doss
leur plan est vraiment problématique
certains vont dire qu'ils veulent le
beurre et l'argent du beurre
en tout cas ils ont au moins la
bénédiction de la reine ici mathieu
prost radio-canada à montréal